[Musique]
voilà il y avait et span ont ri et là il
y avait derrière rentrée avec en dessert
des ananas du carrid espagne ou au
combat va et des steaks de tomber rose
c'est demi pensionnaires du collège des
aigrettes endroit ce midi un menu
spécialement composée à 100% de poissons
pays
une action menée en partenariat avec
l'interprofession de la pêche et de
l'aquaculture à la reine y auront
produit tout ça des pélagiques du sommet
pélagiques des poissons vaut donc voilà
nous on peut apporter la petite pierre à
ce qu'ils mangent du poisson ça sera
très bien pour leur santé déjà et et
poids production locale pour l'économie
locale
une filière qui représente 2 138 emplois
directs et un chiffre d'affaires annuel
de 18 millions d'euros
ces collégiens ont également échangé
avec des pêcheurs locaux qui sont au
coeur de cette filière je suis cinquième
génération de pêcheurs d'antan ont pêché
empêché à la marche pêcher à la main on
descendait jusqu'à 700 m au fond avec un
plomb et il fallait tirer à la main
cette action pleine de succès vient
appuyer la place du poisson pays dans la
restauration scolaire quatre tonnes sont
ainsi proposés chaque année dans les
assiettes de nos marmailles
[Musique]